your ever I said have a look at this
first example if you've got the equation
just find some points that satisfy that
equation and you get points on the line
okay you can pick any course you like
but they suggest in the exercise when
you're economic thanks just particular
points it suggests the x-intercept and
the y-intercept can anyone tell me what
do those mean what is x-intercept me you
reckon very good so didn't quite catch
that
this is alive this is an online each of
these lines here's the corner axes at
some particular point right are this
region perhaps so it hits each axis the
x intercept is where you hit the x axis
the y intercept is where you hit the y
axis cred so in order to find each of
these to find the x intercept you let y
or the error excuse me and to find the y
intercept you let X equal 0
then we'll get weird that's backwards
since often confuse this excuse me just
look at the line of time the x intercept
why do you let y equal 0 what is y equal
0 have to do with the x intercept excuse
me can you look at the x axis with me
for a second we're in the x axis here it
is
all right I better label time and
there's the x axis and the y axis okay
do you see every round the x axis you're
not off you're not down you're exactly
in the middle right what that means is
vertically you have an increase you have
a decrease and that's what this means Y
means vertical values under if it's zero
it's not positive and it's not negative
it's right there on the line
it's only
okay so let's actually try it let's see
what happens he is the equation I'm
going to let y equal zero zero equals 3x
minus one so now I need to solve for X
that's the x intercept
can someone tell me what to do what can
do to both sides that might help me be
yes very okay if I add one to both sides
that gives me a 1 over here what did you
give you on the right in Federer if I
add one to both sides if you add one to
this what happens yeah that negative one
as the one they become nothing they do
leave the 3x behind er right good know
the answer so she for now what I do what
I do this is an improvement I'm still a
fish
I should divide now my treat by the way
why do I divide by 3 why don't say like
subtract 3 because 3 subtracting 3 - can
we get through three right why not
subtract it because it's yeah there's a
multiplication sign hiding in there so
you're undoing multiplication by
division so I'll divide by 3 I might as
well get the X on the left-hand side I
usually do that when I'm solving
something so that gives me x equals 1
over 3 1/3 okay just just keep that in
your head for a second let's do the
other intercept if I want a y-intercept
I'm going to let X equal zero all the
way around so let's do that
touching very easy y equals I'm letting
X equal zero right so this is 3 times 0
minus 1 will switch on 0 is 0 so y is
just negative 1 ok now we've got all the
information we need draw yourself a set
of axes
like so choose an appropriate scale so
I'm actually going to put negative one
looks funny one
imma put a negative one all the way down
there okay I am going to try to keep my
scales consistent even though I have to
just make my brows and easier to read if
that's where negative one is that's
negative 2/3 and negative 1/3 so I'm
going to put positive 1/4 over there 0 X
1 do you see how I've used this
information x equals 1/3 to put it there
I should label that to add this
information to say wife executive one
done one ok anyone any questions so all
right yeah so you see how it's taking
this probation I've chopped it onto the
diagram and just like before now I just
have to join it up there y equals 3x